ce jeudi 20 juillet dans la matinée
c'était la toute première séance
d'entraînement du PSG ouverte aux médias
dans ce nouveau Training Center du PSG
Flambo 9 ici à Poissy on a pu assister
au 15 premières minutes d'entraînement
et on peut dire que les joueurs du club
de la capitale semble avoir pris leur
marque ici tout sourire on a pu voir les
nouvelles recrues comme screenya ou
encore Asensio et bien sûr Lucas
Hernandez arrivé fraîchement du Bayern
Munich pour plus de 45 millions d'euros
on a pu voir aussi à Neymar qui était en
jambe on a pu le voir faire des taureaux
avec Kylian Mbappe le reste du groupe
qui vient de Mbappe qui pourrait partir
dans les prochains jours au Real Madrid
on ne sait pas et on est suspendu à sa
décision en tout cas il était très
proche de son frère Ethan Mbappe et de
Neymar sur le terrain d'entraînement du
PSG ici à Poissy demain ce vendredi 21
juillet le Paris Saint-Germain disputera
son tout premier match amical de
l'intersaison contre Le Havre ici sans
public dans ce train ING Center de
Poissy les joueurs parisiens
s'envoleront le lendemain ce samedi
direction le Japon pour une tournée
estivale avant la reprise du championnat